you and khabib used to get along you
were friendly what happened there are no
friends in this business I had a fan
originally so the man was a fan and then
you know things change and that's it so
I don't have friends in this business
it's a ruthless ruthless business Conan
so no friends Connor yeah
Connor first of all you just described
my business you I mean this is intense
this is a this this is a real anger this
is a real there's a real bloodlust here
for lack of a better term in the press
conference you stared into khabib eyes
and there was an intensity to that stare
that's rarely seen I believe in in any
walk of life what did you see when you
looked in his eyes I saw what I've seen
many times when I've looked at that man
his eyeballs turned to glass the blood
rushes from his body and Sprint's out of
his arse so that's what I saw another
hair you're saying a man throws at his
body and shot out of his rectum that's
what you're saying
yes projectile
you saying that that's pure does he fear
you yes yes 100% he fears we'll see that
on Saturday night you will see if you
will see a scared man
I'm scared talking to you about this my
ass is bleeding at this moment it's been
all day yeah it's my diet Conor
you